SAILESH KRISHNAMURTHY: Hello,
welcome to this session
on innovating with
transformative databases
for an always-on digital world.
My name is Sailesh
Krishnamurthy,
and I lead engineering for cloud
native databases at Google.
Today I am thrilled to
have Hari Ramamurthy, who
is a technology fellow at
the Home Depot join us.
Hari will share how the Home
Depot uses Google's cloud
native databases to
transform their business
in the modern digital world.
We'll begin today
by talking about
transformative capabilities
and why they're so important.
Next we'll review our
transformative databases,
Spanner, Bigtable,
and Firestore,
and the new innovations we are
bringing to this portfolio.
And then we'll hear from
Hari on how the Home
Depot uses these databases.
Today's innovators
are disrupting
traditional industries by
using data and software
to deliver personalized and
seamless digital experiences
across devices and channels.
Modern conveniences, like
buy online, pickup in-store,
instant digital payments,
real time ride ridesharing
requests, and other
marketplace services
have raised the bar in consumer
experiences with the respect
to the size and the
complexity of the problem,
or even how regulated
the industry is.
These disruptive
experiences require
sophisticated and
complex applications
that need to serve millions
of users in a reliable
and continuously
available fashion,
skillfully handle viral growth
and unpredictable spikes
in demand without
missing a beat,
and securely deal
with bad actors,
and comply with stringent
regulatory regimes.
Speed is critical, and
you need the flexibility
to iterate quickly and deliver
innovative and differentiated
experiences for your customers.
The key to scalably and securely
serving millions of users
is an operational database
that'll power your applications
and run your business.
You need databases with
transformative capabilities.
And the new table stakes are an
availability SLA of five nines,
with zero maintenance downtime,
and automatic failure recovery.
That's at most five minutes
of downtime every year.
Online and unlimited
scaling and zero
touch global and
multi-region deployments.
And most important,
the highest security,
complying with the industry's
most demanding standards.
At Google Cloud
we offer not one,
but three
transformative databases
that provide the
capabilities that you
need to deliver innovative
customer experiences.
These are Spanner,
Bigtable, and Firestore.
And through these
databases, you get
to access the very same
groundbreaking technologies
that power the Google apps that
we all love and use every day,
Search, YouTube, Gmail, Maps.
Each of these are used by
billions of users worldwide.
And while data is born
in operational databases,
these are only the first
part of a bigger journey.
Our database services are
deeply integrated with a larger
ecosystem of market leading
data and AI services that
are part of Google Cloud.
These include services like
BigQuery, GKE, DataFlow,
DataStream, Pub/Sub, Cloud
Functions, and so on.
And these services
help you break down
your operational silos,
build data pipelines,
generate real time insights, and
make better business decisions.
In 2021 we delivered many
new features and enhancements
across the entire portfolio.
Some of the more
notable ones include
customer managed encryption
keys, data access audit
logging, key visualizers
for observability,
and an availability
SLA of up to five nines
for Bigtable, matching that
of Spanner and Firestore.
And today we are
excited to share
how we are raising the
bar yet again with more
new innovations.
Let's take a closer look.
Spanner is a fully managed
relational database
with global scale,
asset transactions,
and full SQL support,
strong consistency
across regions and
continents, high availability,
up to five nines with
zero scheduled downtime.
To give you a sense of the
magnitude of its scale,
Spanner processes over a billion
requests per second at peak.
There's never, ever been
a relational database
with the scale of Spanner.
And now we want to
democratize Spanner and make
it available to everyone.
Earlier this year we announced
granular instance sizing, which
is available in
preview, and works
based on a new concept of
Processing Units, or PUs.
A node is made of 1,000
PUs, and you can now
get started by
commissioning 100 PUs.
You can scale up in steps of
100 PUs without any downtime,
going from 100, 200, 300,
all the way to 1,000 PUs,
which is one node.
And you can then scale
out by adding capacity
in increments of 1,000 PUs,
1,000, 2,000, 3,000, or a node
at a time.
With granular instance
configurations,
you will be able
to provision one
tenth of a current node
for one tenth the price,
and can now get started with
Spanner for just $65 a month.
We think this is a game
changer for customers
who need smaller instances
for smaller and medium sized
workloads, and also
unlocks creativity
and innovation for smaller
teams on tight budgets.
PostgreSQL has emerged today as
the de facto industry standard
for relational
databases as businesses
accelerate to the cloud.
And today I am excited to
announce Cloud Spanner's
Postgres interface, which
further democratizes access
to Spanner for millions
of developers and ISPs.
This interface combines
the power and reliability
of Spanner with the familiarity
and portability of Postgres.
With the Postgres
interface, enterprises
looking to standardize
on Postgres
can now take advantage of
Spanner's global scale,
five nines availability,
and strong consistency using
the skills and tools of the
popular and ubiquitous Postgres
ecosystem.
Spanner's Postgres interface
is now available in preview,
and we'd love your feedback.
If you are interested,
please sign up on the URL
listed on the slide.
Bigtable is a fully managed,
scalable, NoSQL database
for large, operational,
and analytical workloads,
with an industry
leading availability
SLA of up to five nines.
It's ideal for apps that require
consistent, single digit,
millisecond latencies,
and need to support
high throughput, millions
of requests per second.
Bigtable scales seamlessly
from a first gigabyte
to petabyte scale.
And in fact, Bigtable
has more than 10 exabytes
of data under management.
It also integrates with
the Apache ecosystem
and supports the HBase API.
And today I'm excited to share
that autoscaling is coming soon
to Bigtable.
With autoscaling, Bigtable will
automatically add or remove
capacity in response
to the changing demands
of your workloads.
So you only pay for the
capacity that you need.
Autoscaling reduces management
overhead, as your teams can now
spend more time
on your business,
and less time managing
your infrastructure.
And we've also doubled the
storage units for Bigtable
so you can now store
more data cheaply.
Bigtable nodes now support
twice as much storage capacity.
From SSD you go from a limit
of two and a half terabytes
per node to a maximum of
five terabytes per node,
and for HDD, from 8
terabytes per node
to a maximum of 16
terabytes per node.
This is especially more cost
effective for batch workloads
that operate on large
amounts of data.
Firestore is our fully managed,
scalable, and truly serverless
document database that lets
you easily and rapidly develop
rich mobile and
web applications.
All this with an availability
SLA of up to five
nines that's achieved through
strongly consistent data
replication.
Developers love Firestore
because of its ability
to serve both as a
document database
and as a backend
business service.
It's therefore, no
surprise that Firestore
has built a thriving
developer community
with more than 250,000 monthly
active developers and Firestore
apps powering more than 750
million monthly active end
users using Firebase Auth.
You can develop and
deploy apps fast,
with direct connectivity
to the database,
no middle tier needed.
These apps can have rich and
collaborative experiences
with built-in real time live
synchronization across devices,
as well as seamless
support for disconnected
or an offline mode.
Firestore's developer
experience truly sets it apart.
And we continue to invest
heavily in this area.
With Key Visualizer, customers
can quickly and visually
identify performance issues.
With the latest
version of our web SDK,
we've added tree shaking,
which reduces the SDK footprint
by as much as 80%.
A smaller SDK means faster
load times for your app.
Both Key Visualizer and the new
web SDK are available today.
We also graduate the Unity
and C++ SDKs to general
availability in Q4.
Both of these SDKs
make it easier
to develop mobile
games using Firestore.
We're excited about
mobile gaming.
As game developers have
told us how Firestore lets
them quickly build and
iterate on their games.
In addition to
developer friendliness,
we've been focused
on making Firestore
more enterprise friendly, with
a strong commitment to security
and privacy.
Data access audit
logs in preview
lets privileged
administrators audit
all operations, admin, and
data on a Firestore database.
Custom IAM in GA lets you
align Firestore permissions
with your organization's
IAM roles.
In addition to
these enhancements,
I'm excited to
announce new features.
With VPC service
controls customers
will be able to reduce
exfiltration risks
through network level security
controls that include Firestore
in a security perimeter.
And with App Check,
customers will
be able to ensure only signed
and pre-authorized apps
are allowed to make
requests to Firestone.
We'll roll out previews
for VPC service controls
and App Check in Q4.
Let's now take a look
at real world examples
and hear from Hari on
how the Home Depot is
using these transformative
databases for a variety of use
cases.
HARI RAMAMURTHY:
Thank you, Sailesh.
Home Depot is the largest
home improvement retailer
in the US with close to
2,000 stores in the US.
But specifically in the context
of this last year that's
been so unprecedented,
the amount of stress
that we've been placing on
all our IT systems in general
has really been significant.
And thanks to the Google
platform overall and many
of these databases, I think
our systems have actually
come out doing quite well during
these really challenging times.
Some of the key
metrics, if you really
look at it in the course of
this really extraordinary period
that we are in, we're delighted
that we grew our business
in 2020 by $21 billion.
86% of the digital sales growth
and over $3.6 billion visits
to our website are some
of the key metrics that
underscore the criticality
of the technology platforms
and solutions that we've been
running through this period.
Let's look at Cloud Spanner and
its usage in some more detail.
There are multiple scenarios
in the organization,
especially in areas
like supply chain,
or order management, or loyalty
where it is really critical
that the system state
moves from one atomic,
ACID compliance state to another
consistent transactional state.
And we need to do
this in addition
to those systems actually being
available in multiple data
centers and serving
traffic coming
from various regions
to these APIs
and the databases
that power them.
And this is really
where Spanner has
been a key player in
ensuring that we're
meeting the level
of service that
is expected of our customers.
To look at Spanner
in some more detail,
I think the fact that
we, in these areas,
are able to deploy our software
on three or more data centers
and have really large
volumes of data--
I mean, the 10 TB is still
where we are currently
and we see that growing rapidly.
But be able to serve the
traffic that's coming through
in multiple data centers,
and have the system move
from that one consistent
transactional state to another
has been really key in making
sure that we are always
not only serving traffic
at extremely high volumes,
but we do not have to do it with
any fear about the consistency
with which the system
is actually performing.
In addition, capabilities
like secondary indices
has been really helpful
in some of these scenarios
in making sure that
we can access the data
and reach the appropriate
pattern of usage,
depending on the context.
The fact that we
are fundamentally
able to deploy these
applications that
have strong consistency
guarantees without needing
to worry about uptime,
and be able to serve
our customers in these
various geographical zones
has really been a
game changer for us.
And it's something
that we've been
really excited to use
and employ as part
of our overall strategy.
On the other side
of the spectrum,
there are also multiple
scenarios where we may not
need the strong
consistency guarantees,
but we have extremely demanding
requirements with regards
to the response time
of the database,
as well as the scale
of the database.
And this is really
where Bigtable's
been a game changer for us.
A specific case in point
is on the website where
we employ personalized
experiences for our customers,
we've been able to tailor
these experiences at extremely
high volumes based
on the journey
that the customer has taken,
combine it with prior purchase
history, as well as both
static and dynamic rules
that we've actually learned
based on customer shopping
behaviors.
And some of these
requirements demand
that we easily scale
up to thousands
of transactions per second.
And we've been able to do
that quite effortlessly
with Bigtable.
In addition, there are scenarios
like inventory aggregation
where we really have to
bring together the inventory
picture across our network,
both the stores and the supply
chain, and be able to do this
in a matter of milliseconds
so that we are able to
appropriately promise
to our customers
the inventory that's
available in various locations.
And we're really glad that we
chose Bigtable as the platform
to bring some of
these experiences.
I think it's noteworthy that
in many of these scenarios,
we are dealing with certainly
thousands of transactions
per second during
regular processes,
but in scenarios like
the recommendations,
there are scenarios where we
need to process certain batch
processes that may push up
the database's transaction
throughput to up to 450,000
transactions per second.
And we do this on a consistent
basis for short periods of time
without needing to
employ a large cluster
throughout the period, but
rather just bringing up
the increased number of
nodes when we need it,
and then going back to a
more regular sized cluster.
As mentioned here, currently
that's typically from 10
to up to 30 nodes.
And we're really excited about
having this type of elasticity
come to play.
In addition, the fact that we're
able to serve these extremely
high volumes of
traffic without having
to worry about maintaining
these databases,
worrying about updates,
and be able to do it
in that multi datacenter
set up that is almost
necessary for our
scales and volumes
has been truly a
game changer and has
allowed us to deal
with the type of spikes
that we have seen through
the course of this last year.
Firestore is another
really interesting database
that we're doing
some prototypes with.
And the specific
capability of Firestore,
with its offline
capabilities both from a read
as well as from a write
through cache standpoint
is something that's
of great interest.
And there are certain scenarios
across our stores in home
where we really believe
that this capability could
come in really handy.
And we're currently
in the process
of prototyping this database.
And we're really excited
by what it has to offer.
SAILESH KRISHNAMURTHY:
Thank you, Hari,
for sharing how the Home
Depot is innovating customer
experiences with
Google Cloud Databases
and driving the growth
of your business
in this very challenging and
interesting time for all of us.
Google Cloud Databases provide
a groundbreaking platform
for innovation
based on decades of
our own firsthand experiences
with shaping the digital world.
We offer the highest levels
of availability, reliability,
and global scale,
enabling you to deliver
the best possible experiences
for your customers.
There is tons more
exciting content at Next.
And I encourage
you all to attend
these sessions to learn more
about Spanner, Bigtable,
and Firestore.
To dive deeper,
take the Qwiklabs.
Thank you all so much
for your time today.